everyone has a halloween they'll always
remember
and this is jake's
jake you into vintage no i'm into retro
oh
what's the difference about 10 bucks
fair enough
look at that someone took the butcher
knife
[Music]
hi i'm chuckie
you want to play
jake are you okay i can't stand the set
of blood
[ __ ] oh
no jake that isn't quite right what
happened to you jake
you used to have friends
don't forget your boy toy
[Applause] [Music]
okay
it's contagious isn't it laughing at
people
well guess what and now the joke's on
you
hi i'm chuck and i'm your friend to the
end
what did you do
mommy says real killing is bad yeah well
mommy's full of [ __ ]
look around you it's the world series of
slaughter
[Music]
did you feel that everywhere
jake wheeler goes death seems to follow
creepy doll just creeps me the hell out
it's kill
or be killed everybody's gotta choose
what's going on with you you wouldn't
believe me if i told you
chucky he's gone dude
you have a secret style problem if you
only know
[Music]
hey kid i'm gonna go kill your sister
wanna come are you sleepy
you snooze you lose
you